okay welcome back
welcome to overtime
okay here are the questions with donald
trump avoiding prosecution in new york
and the soccer family being shielded
from criminal liability over
purdue pharma is it time to admit that
money can buy you impunity uh well that
was always the case so i was gonna say
it's been that's like a long time ago
what time is it that they admitted that
years ago but the trump one is
astounding
i mean i think two people in that office
now have
resigned over the decision not to
prosecute them and we're talking about
the family business they were going
after in new york and one of them i
think is out in the news this week
saying he's guilty that they he believes
that trump's guilty of multiple felonies
almost in public he is this is this has
been going on for a long time now and
and and look i get it we normally don't
prosecute former presidents in this
country
but this guy was indifferent bad stuff
and why did why did the d.a in new york
make that decision no no is that brag
i don't understand i don't know okay i'd
love where are good investigative
reporters to find out that answer we're
investigating the question of soviet ass
buzzers worse
ever since that last came ever since
that came up
i've been devoting all my investigative
energy to that question um well speaking
of that how would the u.s military
respond
to a nuclear or chemical attack on
ukraine and unfortunately we have to
consider that possibility don't we yeah
i think that is the well let's ask you
and then ask a senator what what uh what
do you think
well um you know we were talking earlier
and i joke that putin is just like me
and you obviously he's not because he is
considering using chemical weapons and
nuclear and he's put the nuclear weapons
use on the table repeatedly
and i think that is a question for
rhetorically we don't know if he means
it
uh it's bad enough to do that but he
wouldn't i don't know if there's i don't
know if there's a difference at a
certain point if the leader of a nuclear
power threatens to use it says he's put
his forces on alert on like defcon
whatever um i think it's happened before
yeah people have raised that level up to
well you have to take it seriously yeah
you have to take it seriously but it
could be just brink brinksmanship i'm
what i'm saying is i don't know what's
in his mind right and he must i'm that's
why i asked you about like how rational
is he i mean he always seemed like a
rational guy but nuclear would be taking
it even chemical but especially to a
level
that the world would change so immensely
a lot of his propagandists have been
saying you know what is the point of a
world
existing if russia doesn't exist in it
and i what is so scary about that is
i think putin feels so cornered and so
trapped by the mistakes that he has made
in this campaign
and it's become so existential for him
that he might do crazy irrational things
the question is if he does it in ukraine
and not in a nato country does nato
respond and now there's talk of well if
the cloud crosses over into a nato
country is that that's the thing is that
considered an attack a nuclear bomb on
any of us is a nuclear attack on all of
us that's right
i mean this is the topic actually of
this sunday's showtimes the circus and
and we we are looking at this very
question it's like it's been a crazy
week i mean you've got not only all the
things putin's been doing throughout the
war you know as biden was headed to
brussels you had members of the dumont
on state tv saying if nato rolls out
peacekeeping forces we should nuke
warsaw now you know how seriously you
take that but julia's right i mean the
reality is that because in in the old
days when you had mutually sure
destruction it was like the attack would
have been russia attacked soviet union
attacking united states or vice versa
both of them decided not to do that
because they knew they would both you
know incinerate both places in this case
you've got the situation where
putin is more likely to detonate a a
tactical nuke what happens if putin
decides that he wants in his desperation
decides he wants to send a tactical nuke
into keiv it's like well there is no
nato nato doctrine of self-defense there
and so one of the things that they're
discussing they've been discussing
behind the scenes is that question they
don't want to come out and say what they
will do and they have not but the
question of what do you do in that
situation and and knowing that every war
game model that's ever been done
one you get one escalation you get one
tactical nuke that you respond with one
it very quickly turns out to be in five
hours there's 90 million people dead so
it's like it's a the escalation ladder
ramps up very fast in that situation so
figuring out what to do about that how
to posture on it it's a really really
hard question and it's interesting i
mean this is such a change in moscow
because in soviet times as [ __ ] up as
that system was they at least understood
that a nuclear war was unwinnable for
anybody right right and now they seem to
think well define war and define nuclear
and what if it's a small nuke what if
it's like a nitty bitty nuke and it's
just on kiev which is not in a nato
country
do we get away with it right and and as
for bring
brinksmanship you know for months as he
was building up uh so many troops around
the border with ukraine surrounding it
all three sides there were a lot of
people who were saying he's not going to
do it that's crazy right it's just
brinksmanship yeah yeah no no so we have
to believe him when he says what he's
going to do the the chemical weapons
issue um and you touched on it um
the world has to be outraged at this and
and
i think it is absolutely a game changer
it could cause escalation like we've
never seen before and bad should happen
but
but maybe on the other hand um
you know if if we could get china to
join us in the sanctions
it would bring them to their knees just
that fast not that the sanctions aren't
working a lot very very well right now
but they're only out of china that's
they're only out right now but again i'm
sorry i love you john i have to do this
because you are a senator yeah i have to
press you on it yes the nuke let's say
he does fire a nuke what does the united
states do what do you vote that we do
you are one of the 535 people if we
still have a constitution where it's the
congress that declares war because we
don't really i mean that they gave up
that power a long time ago and the
president seems to have taken over
unilaterally which is wrong but we could
get into that in another date but let's
say it's still up to the congress how to
respond what they're you say we do a
nuclear attack on kiev
i'm i'm telling you that the response
would be very very bad
would be very very bad because you would
respond in a like manner
and then that that sounds like firing
off a nuclear weapon and another
response
i am telling you that i don't think you
can take anything
off the table at this moment in time
um
and i think it could escalate just as
john hallman has said in a way that
none of us
want to see right i mean the problem is
the situation gets ramped up to the
point where everyone's on high alert you
know there's the in war there's a lot of
confusion nobody knows really what's
going on there's a lot of misperception
you've got the the phone lines are
basically cut
normally you would have our secretary of
defense talking to his counterpart in in
moscow not happy they're not taking the
phone calls so we don't really know what
they're thinking or even what they're
saying they're thinking and in a
situation like that where
tensions are escalated no one knows what
the other side is thinking or what
they're doing what's posturing what's
not the worry is more is not like
putin's gonna nuke manhattan or london
or paris but that a mistake gets made
a missile gets launched no one sure what
it is it's it's the it's the it's the
possibility for error a small error that
then triggers the response that is what
we have to respond
that's a different issue
we're talking about that
manufactured error i talked about that
last week there have been many nukes
that have been lost yes there were a
couple of cases in 83 and 95 where they
all they the soviets thought at 83 it
was the russians in 95. thought that an
attack was underway but they didn't
respond because oh no it's just birds or
something or our radar screwed up
we're talking about yes let's not avoid
the question
a deliberate attack and it's the
ultimate like there are no good answers
there's only the least bad and i'm kind
of with you that the least bad answer
that you have to go to is that it cannot
stand you cannot set the precedent that
you can nuke somebody and get away with
it which means that you have to nuke
maybe that doesn't mean moscow but it i
just think how else are you going to
live in a world where someone thinks
because there is how many nuclear powers
10 now and there's going to be more yeah
you have to it's just here's the other
thing can i just add another thing that
we've already uh gotten to a point
that's really bad uh with ukraine
getting invaded like this now a second
time ukraine gave up the nuclear weapons
on its territory in 1994 in exchange for
territorial sovereignty they were
granted there were no concrete uh
guarantees in the agreement that
somebody would fight for them but now
you know after what happened with libya
what happened with ukraine if i'm a
small country i want nukes because then
nobody will invade me it's the it's the
problem with the with the proliferation
pressure now everybody's going to want
to have nukes because they've seen how
this has played out but i will again
i'll say billion when they do these war
game scenarios which is all we ever do
right because we haven't actually had a
nuclear war since 1945 we haven't
dropped any nuclear weapons when they do
them there's a moment in the scenario
the first thing happens right russia
launches let's say one tactical nuke at
that moment there's a choice to make do
you respond with a nuclear commensurate
single tactical nuclear war warhead back
or do you stay conventional in most of
the simulations if you choose nuclear
you end up with 100 million people dead
very fast right because of the way the
the systems are built to escalate and so
for a lot of people you might this might
be the wrong political answer but that
if you that that is the gate it's that
first response and once that once you go
through one gate or the other you are on
the path very quickly towards uh not
inevitable but very likely global
devastation or not and again it's one of
the trickiest things so i think when the
government runs these these tests they
say they almost always end up with total
global thermal nuclear war there's no
this is just unwinnable it's the way
that things are built they're built to
kill and escalate
great note to end on yeah
have a great oscar weekend everybody
[Applause]
you